"
THEY WERE AMONG THE VICTORS."
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT" ."
IT IS THIS WEEK, THE YEAR
ANNIVERSARY OF THE BEGINNING OF
THE ROBERT MUELLER RUSH
INVESTIGATION AT THE END OF THAT
PERIOD WE HAVE DISCOVERED THERE
IS STILL NO EVIDENCE AT ALL OF
COLLUSION BETWEEN THE
DONALD TRUMP FOR
PRESIDENT CAMPAIGN OF 2016 AND
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT BUT
MUELLER'S MANY SUPPORTERS IN
WASHINGTON DON'T SEEM TO CARE
ABOUT THAT.
THAT'S BECAUSE THE INVESTIGATION
WAS NEVER ABOUT RUSSIA,
OBVIOUSLY.
THE WHOLE ABSURD FEVER DREAM WAS
ALWAYS A WAY FOR THE RULING
CLASS TO FEEL BETTER ABOUT
LOSING POWER IN 2016.
IT WAS A WAY FOR THEM TO AVOID
THINKING ABOUT WHY TRUMP GOT
ELECTED.
THEY NEVER HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT
IT.
ALONG THE WAY THE INVESTIGATIONS
PROVIDED DEMOCRATS WITH A FULL
YEAR OF GOVERNMENT-FUNDED IPO
RESEARCH AND DESTROYED THE LIVES
OF A NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
SUPPORTED DONALD TRUMP.
THERE HAVE BEEN DOWNSIDES FOR
DEMOCRATS.
VOTERS ARE NOT IMPRESSED BY THE
RUSSIA STORY.
IT IS WEIRD AND FALSE AND
CONFUSING AND IT'S PRECISELY
NOTHING TO DO WITH VOTERS ACTUAL
LIVES OF THE ISSUES THEY VOTE
ON.
IT IS A TOTAL WASTE OF TIME FOR
EVERYONE.
AND YET IT'S ALL DEMOCRATS HAVE.
TRUMP IS EVIL, SO IS RUSSIA.
THAT'S THE ENTIRE PROGRESSIVE
PROGRAM 2018 SUMMARIZED INTO
SENTENCES.
IF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAD A
ATTITUDES.
NO WONDER THEIR APPROVAL NUMBERS
ARE FALLING.
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN HAS
INTRODUCED OVER THE RESOLUTION
CALLING FOR AN END TO MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION OR A REPORT WITHIN
30 DAYS.
HE JOINS ALONG WITH RON
DeSANTIS OF FLORIDA.
HE SAYS HE MAY KNOW THE IDENTITY
OF THE PERSON WHO WAS SPIED ON
TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN FOR THE FBI IN
2016.
GENTLEMEN, WELCOME TO YOU BOTH
TONIGHT.
CONGRESSMAN, FIRST TO YOU.
THIS RESOLUTION WOULD CALL FOR
AN END TO THE INVESTIGATION OR A
REPORT SUMMARIZING ITS FINDINGS
SO FAR.
AM I MISSTATING THAT?
>> BOTH CORRECT.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS IT'S
BEEN A YEAR.
AS YOU SAY, IT'S BEEN
$20 MILLION AND WE NEED TO SEE A
REPORT ON WHAT EVIDENCE HE HAS
AND ABSENT THAT EVIDENCE IT
SHOULD WIND UP WITHIN 30 DAYS OF
THE RESOLUTION PASSING.
>> Tucker: SO WHY WOULDN'T
OTHER MEMBERS ON BOTH SIDES IN
THE CONGRESS WANT SOME OVERSIGHT
AND?
IF YOU ARE CONSTITUTIONALLY
BOUND TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT OF
THE DOJ, WHY ARE YOU THE ONLY
PERSON CALLING FOR THIS?
>> ARE NOT.
MATT GATES IS ALSO CALLING FOR
IT.
THERE'S A COUPLE OTHER CALLING
PORTS.
CALL YOUR MEMBER OF CONGRESS AND
GET THEM ON BOARD.
YOU CAN ONLY HAVE A FREE
REPUBLIC, AS YOU KNOW, IF YOU
HAVE TRANSPARENCY AND THIS IS
EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED.
IT IS A WITCH HUNT.
IT HAS GONE BEYOND AN
INVESTIGATION AND THE ONLY
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION WE FOUND,
THE ONLY EVIDENCE OF CRIMINALITY
HAS BEEN ON THE DEMOCRATS.
WE ARE CALLING ON MUELLER TO
SHOW HIS HAND OR FOLD THE DECK.
>> Tucker: EVEN IF I BELIEVED
THE PRESIDENT COLLUDED WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN I'D BE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE THE
PARAMETERS AREN'T CLEAR.
THE TIMELINE IS OPAQUE AND IT'S
NOT CLEAR WHAT THE POINT IS.
CONGRESSMAN, ONE OF THE ENDURING
MYSTERIES OF THE PAST TWO WEEKS
HAS BEEN THE STORY OF A MOLE OR
SPY WITHIN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
FEEDING INFORMATION TO THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
HAVE YOU ANY SENSE WHO THAT
PERSON MIGHT BE?
>> I DO, TUCKER, BUT I THINK
THAT THE ISSUE NEEDS TO GO
THROUGH THE TROUBLE SO MY PROPER
CHANNELS.
I'M NOT COMFORTABLE DISCLOSING
WHO I THINK IT IS BASED ON THE
EVIDENCE THAT I HAVE, BUT I CAN
SAY THIS, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DESERVE AN ANSWER.
UP OR DOWN, DID THE FBI DIRECT
SOMEBODY TO SPY ON
DONALD TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN?
WAS SOMEBODY ACTIVELY WORKING TO
UNDERMINE HIS CAMPAIGN AND
CREATE THE ILLUSION OF
COLLUSION?
AND IF THAT'S THE CASE, I THINK
THAT'S MORE SERIOUS THAN THE
FISA ABUSE.
I THINK IT'S MORE SERIOUS THAN
ROSENSTEIN BUTCHERING THIS WHOLE
APPOINTING ORDER WITH MUELLER
FROM THE BEGINNING.
WE NEED THE ANSWER TO THOSE
QUESTIONS.
THEY ARE NOT GIVING US THE
ANSWERS RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE DEFINITELY
NOT.
I KNOW YOU DON'T WANT TO RISK
LIBEL BY NAMING SOMEONE BECAUSE
THIS IS NOT BEEN PROVED IN
COURT, BUT GIVE US A SENSE OF
WHAT YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT.
ARE YOU SAYING SOMEONE WHO
WORKED ON THE DRUM CAMPAIGN FED
INFORMATION TO LAW ENFORCEMENT?
>> SO IF YOU LOOK AT GLEN
SIMPSON'S TESTIMONY FROM
FUSION GPS, HE TALKED ABOUT
THERE BEING A HUMAN SOURCE AND
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
CONTROVERSIAL.
SOME PEOPLE SAID IT WAS
PAPADOPOULOS.
IT'S NOT PAPADOPOULOS.
THE ISSUE IS HE ACKNOWLEDGES
THERE'S A HUMAN SOURCE.
PETER STRZOK, HE OPENS UP THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION IN 2016, WHAT DOES
HE DO THE NEXT DAY?
HE GOES TO GREAT BRITAIN AND HE
GOES TO LONDON AND HE'S MEETING
WITH PEOPLE.
HOW THE HECK WOULD YOU DO THAT
IF YOU JUST OPEN THE
INVESTIGATION THAT DAY?
I THINK IN THAT KIND OF, THE
LONDON, CHRISTOPHER STEELE,
GLENN SIMPSON ACCESS IS PROBABLY
THE INDIVIDUAL WE ARE LOOKING
AT.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHETHER THIS
INDIVIDUAL WAS SPYING OR NOT.
I HAVE GREAT CONCERNS ABOUT IT
BUT I BELIEVE WE CAN GET THOSE
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS WHEN THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT PONIES UP THE
DOCUMENTS.
>> Tucker: ARE YOU SUGGESTING
OR DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
SOMEONE WHO WAS PRESSURED INTO
COOPERATING WITH THE
INVESTIGATION, OR SOMEONE WHO
FREELY SEND INFORMATION OVER
ABOUT THE CAMPAIGN?
>> I THINK IT'S THE LATTER,
TUCKER.
I THINK THIS COULD BE SOMEONE,
POTENTIALLY COULD HAVE BEEN PAID
BY THE FBI, LIKE STEELE.
THERE WAS AN AGREEMENT TO PAY
STEELE.
DID THEY PAY ANYBODY?
YES OR NO.
DID THEY DIRECT ANYBODY TO GO TO
THE CAMPAIGN?
YES OR NO.
VERY EASY QUESTIONS TO ANSWER.
>> Tucker: I'M SORRY,
CONGRESSMAN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
>> RON IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
WE ALSO NEED TO KNOW THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN MUELLER AND
COMEY.
COMEY KICKED THIS WHOLE THING
OFF WITH A BOGUS FISA WARRANT
AND WHAT IS THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN MUELLER AND COMEY?
DID MUELLER GIVE COMEY IMMUNITY?
DOES COMEY THINK HE'S ABOUT THE
LAW?
WHERE ARE WE GOING WITH ALL OF
THIS?
THAT'S WHAT NEEDS TO BE
INVESTIGATED.
>> Tucker: DO BELIEVE,
QUICKLY, CONGRESSMAN, DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT JIM COMEY HAS BEEN
OFFERED IMMUNITY BY THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION?
>> I THINK IT STANDS TO REASON
AND I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DESERVE TO KNOW.